we were lucky enough to have five
amazing seasons of Stargate Atlantis
there was a plan for season six but that
never came to be
today let's talk about the episodes that
were never made but were planned from
the mouth of Joseph malozi himself
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
before we get into this video I'd like
to invite you to join our Discord server
with over 100 people in there we're
already talking about their favorite
science fiction television shows from
Stargate to Battlestar Galactica and
more
join the conversation now by heading to
dsc.gg forward slash Sidetrack or check
the links in the description
now before we get into this video I do
want to put out a little disclaimer
because this video I'm about to show you
was actually filmed and edited almost a
year ago back in April of 2022 when
these tweets first went out it was
originally meant to go out on a Sci-Fi
channel that I'd originally created
around about that time but
within the space of a few days I joined
sidetracks so the video Never officially
went out
so I thought it'd be good and it would
be fun to share that video with you
because the contents of it is actually
really interesting but just bear in mind
there are portions of the video where
I'm basically alluding to the fact that
Stargate might get made again without
knowing at the time that Mark Fergus
orcutsby would have been approached
there would have been a bad robot script
things like that because back then those
things hadn't happened so a little bit
of leeway and I hope you enjoyed the
video entropy in season five Paul wanted
to do a story in which the effects of
the McKay Miller Gate Bridge have
serious otherworldly repercussions for
the city but we ended up doing something
similar in brainstorm so we pushed this
idea so I reimagined a version where the
mishap of a zpm triggers a Subspace
burst that disperses time fractals
throughout Atlantis and Within These
varying shards of warp space-time the
rules of physics no longer reply that
sounds absolutely awesome I have no idea
what a Time fractal is
I know this I can kind of guess what's
going to happen if the rules of physics
no longer reply what kind of mishaps can
happen in Atlantis well I guess we're
never going to find out that that would
be awesome
as an episode
really cool synopsis the next one we
have is called hexed and this one sounds
really fun so while visiting an alien
Community Shepard is cursed by a kooky
local at first Our Heroes laugh off the
instant until Shepard runs into a Spate
of bad luck very bad luck now this one
sounds really cool obviously we know
curses and things like that and Magic
don't really exist it's usually just
technology
um from some Advanced species whether
that's ancient technology or whether
that's another race uh is yet to be
determined I suppose but that sounds
like a really fun episode if you're
running into a Spate of bad luck that
means you can have lots and lots of
mishaps lots and lots of injuries and
it's just gonna be a fun episode the way
I'm the way I'm envisioning it and it
probably isn't meant to be looked at
like this but I'm originally like the
200th episode of Stargate sg1
where it's just a fun episode full of
crazy uh mishaps that happen because of
this hex and uh yeah McKay and everyone
involved is just gonna have to try and
break the curse now this next one is
called yesterday today and tomorrow and
this is probably my favorite one if
Stargate Atlantis season six did
actually get made and this would more
than likely have been my favorite
episode so as I said it's called
yesterday today and tomorrow and the
synopsis is as follows McKay's
experiment with a time traveling puddle
jumper sends duplicate versions of the
team both backwards and forwards in time
the story jumps between three different
timelines five years into the past where
one version of the team struggles to
acquire the puddle jumper and undo the
Damage Done without affecting the
timeline
five years into the future where
Atlantis is under siege by an alien race
introduced in the deadless variations
while another version of the team
attempts to require the jumper so that
they can warmth their past selves
and the present where McKay continues to
tweak his experiment with developments
in each timeline influencing events
in the other on route to a mind-bending
climax that sounds awesome that sounds
absolutely amazing I love time travel
that's why I like Doctor Who that's why
I like that's the future and all of the
time travel stories that have ever
happened in Stargate have absolutely
loved 1969 is probably one of my
favorite episodes in Stargate sg1 along
with the Ashen storyline where they had
to travel send a message back in time as
well with Atlantis the time travel
stories in there where Dr Weir was
traveled 10 000 years in the past
absolutely loved it I just love time
travel stories when they're done right
and this sounds like it's going to be
fantastic episode
I'm talking as if it's going to be made
because I hope it will one day I hope it
comes true fruition whether that's as a
short story and an actual live-action
series being made or you know a webcomic
or something like that I want to see the
story I want to see what happens but I
like the idea of three different
versions of the same team all trying to
do something and each of their actions
influences the other
so if someone does something in the past
it influences the the present which then
influences the future team and that
sounds absolutely awesome it's
mind-bending
um it would be one of those episodes
where you probably watch it and you're
like huh so you have to watch it again
and again until you get it but that
sounds absolutely amazing oh I I really
wish I really wish Stargate Atlantis
wasn't canceled
and finally this is the last one I'm
going to talk about it's called
hamstable sometimes you come up with an
idea fully formed other times it may be
nothing but a vision
in this case a vision of the individual
team members trapped in a giant hamster
ball like containment vessels
compounding the problem is the fact that
they are trapped in a small chamber in
direct line of the Stargate meaning the
next time the gate kawashes they risk
total annihilation
how do they get trapped how do they get
out and most importantly what the hell
else happens in the episode you'll have
to ask writer Alan McCullough
to find out more
now that sounds like an episode
um which again would be very very funny
it sounds like season six was gonna be a
very fun season with a few
um serious episodes mixed in between to
push the narrative off the the
overarching storyline of season six but
it sounds like
season six was going to be incredibly
fun and I'm very very sad that it never
got made and it never
it never bore fruit
as I said at the beginning of the video
These tweets are from Joseph malozi and
he as well as Brad Wright been very
active on social media recently which
has made me super excited for the fact
that they could potentially be a Revival
of Stargate sometime soon what do you
think are you excited do you like the
idea of these storylines let me know
down below and before I forget we also
have a Discord server it's the Sidetrack
Discord server that I manage on behalf
of Jay from Sidetrack where you can come
and talk about anything sci-fi whether
that's Stargate Star Wars Doctor Who
Firefly Battlestar Galactica
or Star Trek it doesn't matter if you
like science fiction you're gonna find a
home there looking forward to you all
coming over and chatting with us but
until next time
stay safe stay curious
take it easy
foreign